je veux le j'aime énormément jean-marie
bien sûr qu'on retrouvera les 20 21 et
22 novembre folies bergère à paris
j'aimerais d'abord qu'on regarde un
petit extrait de votre spectacle momo
jean marie ange où vous allez choisir
après ici trois boîtes trois boîtes il y
aura une blague et des choses dedans il
ya des choses sympas il ya des choses
moins sympa jean-marie viendra les
versets et vous devrez raconter une
blague tente le public n'a pas ri
d'accord à votre blague vous continuer à
rester dans la black box si le public a
ri on refera notre petit tour un bien
sûr et il y aura un autre chroniqueur
qui viendra vous remplacez d'accord marc
alors vous choisissez laquelle la
violette
oui la 2 à 2 salah je fous là grob la
grande vague grande salle à je vais dire
jésus dira jean marie ce qui se trouve
dans les boîtes il y à une boîte où il
ya des sauterelles
il ya une boîte où il ya des serpents il
ya une boîte où il ya de la fausse neige
il ya une boîte où il ya des verts et il
ya une boîte où il ya des cafards
et bien sûr à chaque fois les vous avez
les blagues ici et les blagues alors
attention tenez là venez là venaient à
couper couper le retour à qui voit pas
ce que c'est on peut leur tour s'il vous
plaît merci coupé jean-marie venez voir
avec moi ah ouais ça rapporte
c'est quoi est ce qu'il a fait et donc
vous avez vraiment pas de chance mois
six mois jean marie c'est vous qui allez
y allez c'est pas deux je veux bien y
aller avec vous et si je peux débattre
et dépanner allez on y va avait l'an
dernier salle à quoi peut pas l'ouvrir
en dernier vous voulez changer de boîte
ouais mais qu'elle a choisi on l'ouvrira
dont l'âme est en berne et mais non
d'accord allez pour des gentils il vient
d'arriver
tu sur célé allait bien mais on la fera
après cela alors choisissez notre boîte
à 4 4 1 2 3 4
ne regardez pas la 4c bien vous avez
bien fermer les bois qu'un cas où il y
avait des peuples paulo ouais c'est pas
mal pour démarrer sa balle vous avez
tous et bien c'est bien il va nous
raconter une blague bien sûr du 1 kg de
black de jean-marie toc toc le public à
paris vous sortez pas pu bien sûr aux
français d'après vous devez adopter à
lézignan va regarder vous avez un petit
escabeau
je commençais doivent alors vous
commencerez quand ils vous jettera le
risque humain ça va voler leurs
confrères je vous aime si je lis body ch
mais attention attention là jean marie
catala ne regardez pas s'avouer non
attention jean-marie arrive
allez-y bien sûr c'est la blague bad
ok c'est bon j'ai attentionnel avait
l'art book vous comme qui commence là
vous pouvez y aller alors oui année qui
commence ça peut vous avez arrêté là oui
comment ça semble ailleurs qu elle s
appelleront autre image nouvelle et la
différence entre une majorité un cheval
quelle est la différence entre une
majorité assez dégueulasse [ __ ] mais
non sérieux majorettes et un cheval la
majorette un plus petit chromosome y qui
lui permet de cacher pendant le défilé
lâchiez c'est la majorité tel un petit
chromosomes en plus bas mais pas chier
pendant le défilé
tiens les asticots connard
brest
il a hélas c'est la bague donc on peut
pas le sortir son mari non c'est
impossible
impossible alors père très attention
choisissez une nouvelle boîte ces deux
nouvelles boîtes ou voilà la une la une
à une à une
cela donne aux gens mariés cela donne à
jean marie directement je la donne à
jean marie directement du ceria ceux du
alors faites pas de mal ne leur fait pas
de mal et alors bertrand contre l
attention aux assauts des sauterelles ça
c'est compte tenu de lancer le produit
j'ai vu à temps je vais élever l'ouvrir
comme ça et vous faites exprès blagnac
blague quoi t'as vu la longueur des
blacks c'est ce que dit la jambe droite
à gauche
m
du tout comme ça
alors attendez arrêté il dernière la
blague
attention l'idée la blague il est là
mais attendez alesi on écoute du si ce
que dit la jambe droite à la jambe
gauche d'une blonde alors casse-toi
reste ce que dit la jambe droite à la
jambe gauche d'une bombe en rentrant de
vacances on s'est pas vus depuis trois
semaines viens viens bravo
bertrand est quand même très bon mais
chéri allez on sort des braves est
excellent
elle ne les fait pas de mal aux
sauterelles merci